c'est une info qui fait beaucoup parler
et pas forcément pour les bonnes raisons
la nouvelle est sortie dans l'après
cette semaine un concert de bertrand
cantat en mars 2020 lors d'un festival
mais aussi dans plusieurs salles de
france
un retour qui n'est pas le premier pour
le chanteur qui n'en finit pas de créer
la polémique
à chacune de ses apparitions médiatiques
pour rappel en 2003 il avait été au
coeur d'un fait divers sordide à vilnius
en lituanie alors sur le tournage d'un
film il s'était violemment disputé avec
marie trintignant son épouse de l'époque
la violente en allant jusqu'à la tuer un
homicide pour lequel il sera condamné à
huit ans de prison il n'en purgera que
la moitié alors que beaucoup pensaient
que le chanteur à l'époque star du
groupe noir désir ne reviendrait plus
jamais sur scène après ce terrible fait
divers
bertrand cantat avait fait un premier
retour très polémique en 2010 mais ce
son retour en 2017 qui avait fait le
plus grand bruit
la une du journal les inrocks sur
laquelle il apparaissait avait sonné
pour beaucoup comme une provocation
sous la pression sa tournée de l'époque
avait été avortée et de nombreuses
personnalités s'étaient offusqués de
cette médiatisation comme marlène
schiappa et au nom de quoi devons nous
supporter la promo de celui qui a
assassiné marie trintignant à coups de
poing ne rien laisser passer
et aujourd'hui ce nouveau retour
médiatique s'annonce mal le théâtre qui
devait accueillir la pièce a décidé
d'annuler la venue du chanteur face au
début de la polémique
dans un communiqué il explique en vertu
des pressions multiples et d'une censure
qui ne dit pas son nom l'équipe se voit
contraint d'annuler la représentation du
31 mars 2020 visiblement nombreux sont
ceux qui trouvent que ce retour est tout
à fait déplacé quand pour d'autres
puisqu'il a payé sa dette à la société
bertrand cantat a le droit de reprendre
sa carrière comme tout citoyen alors
selon vous fallait-il annulé le retour
sur scène de bertrand cantat
ça fait énormément parler un bien sur
cette affaire on rappelle c'est ne rien
faire bertrand cantat c'est vrai que
tout le monde a été touché par cette
affaire cc1 féminicide vraiment toute la
france et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
voilà il a purgé une peine de prison
comme vous le savez il veut revenir sur
scène il devait revenir sur scène la
salle de spectacle a annulé donc
finalement son retour sur scène vous
vous pensez que c'est une bonne décision
valérie bénard oui alors j'entends déjà
ce qu'ils vont dire oui il a payé sa
dette à la société
il a le droit d'avoir une seconde chance
est ce une nouvelle vie etc etc je peux
entendre tout ça simplement le métier de
bertrand cantat c'est pas un métier
comme un autre
c'est un métier public c'est un métier
où il est dans la lumière il est pas
plombier il n'est pas comptable donc
évidemment que on ne va pouvoir à chaque
fois on va il va faire une promotion
alors qu'il a fait il y a eu un acte
absolument terrible une femme est morte
donc on qu'ils le veuillent ou non on
sera obligé d'y penser qu'ils le
veuillent ou non ça va susciter l'émoi
qu'il le veuille ou non il est associé à
la mort d'une femme et donc qu'ils le
veuillent ou non il y aura toujours
aussi devant les salles de spectacles
des gens qui vont manifester et à juste
titre moi je pense france et voilà vous
pensez que c'est mal venues qui vous
pensez que pour les humoristes et qu'il
peut faire plein dont il doit arrêter sa
carrière que je suis autant tueuses
d'enfants moi j'ai été la première à
aller au spectacle de bertrand cantat
quant à l'époque noir désir prévu
européenne or aux eurockéennes de
belfort voilà j'ai vu pas mal olympia
j'ai vu partout j'adorais aujourd'hui je
peux plus aller voir bertrand cantat sur
scène parce que moi je pense qu'il a
plein de talent il ne peut plus être sur
scène il peut écrire pour d'autres par
exemple mais dans l'ombre alors on à
cédric qui nous a rejoint merci
d'ailleurs cédric d'être là ce soir vous
avez créé un comité de soutien bertrand
cantat en 2013 techniciens de contrôle
d'habitants en vendée et vous avez créé
donc ce groupe et vous vous regrettez
que bertrand cantat sont obligés de
laisser ses fans dans le silence et vous
dit qu'il ne fallait pas annulé son
retour sur scène pour vous c'est de la
censure
c'est exactement de la censure
après rien n'empêche que ce geste qu'il
a eu envers marine 30 client est
totalement condamnable on le conçoit
bien sauf que moi je vais partir sur un
autre principe
le principe est que il a pu l'appeler
certaine et la purger sa peine
je ne suis pas son avocat nous ne sommes
pas juges et il ya un article du code
pénal qui le 431 si rien n'est dit que
il est condamnable d'empêcher une
artiste de se produire ou de créer d'une
peine de prison pouvant aller jusqu'à un
an et quinze mille euros pour vous c'est
empêcher un artiste qui peuvent ils
peuvent être condamnés d'avoir empêché
bertrand cantat de revenir sur scène
c'est ça vous est ce que vous comprenez
qu'ils les gens qui puissent être
choqués de revoir bertrand cantat mais
bien servi on va voir des images et des
vidéos de sa maman voilà marie
trintignant voilà qui comprend du coup
de revoir bertrand cantat sur scène de
faire sa vie normale alors que leur
fille est morte alors que voilà est-ce
que ça vous dérange pas am je je peux
comprendre tout à fait moi même j'ai des
enfants je comprends que c'est terrible
ça doit être terrible de perdre un
enfant
mais le fait est que il a été jugé
aujourd'hui monde années il a certaines
personnes veulent encore le juger et
l'empêché de se produire ni quoi que ce
soit mais pensez quand même à toutes les
personnes gars on va dire à des millions
de personnes qui demandent que ça à
écouter en comptant non mais profiter de
son art ah ouais alors christophe
derrière vous vous êtes d'accord avec
moi sur le principe annulé à un retour
sur scène je trouve ça nul en revanche
mon avis contrastés oui mais sinon non
parce que le truc c'est que qu'on annule
pas son auteur sur scène en revanche et
sa valérie l'a souligné qui fait du mal
c'est la promo fête moi je pense à jean
louis xiii en france à toute la famille
je pense aux enfants de marie
trintignant à chaque fois oui
on sait oui mais dans les faits est on
est pour ou contre qui reviennent sur
scène mois qu'il a joué dans une mjc
s'il veut absolument jouer ses morceaux
ou même au théâtre là je veux dire le
fait qu'ils interdisent le concert ça
lui fait encore plus de promo matthieu
delormeau pardon mais il ya la loi
monsieur et puis à la décence alors la
loi effectivement il a pris que quelques
années de prison ça sait pas quoi dans
votre temps mais pour lui parce que
c'est la loi et c'était un crime
passionnel n'y a pas d'intention dont il
a pris quelques années voilà tant mieux
pour lui il a pris que quelques années
après à la décence comment ce monsieur
qui j'espère encore toutes les nuits
pense à l'horreur qu'il a fait comment
ce monsieur peut encore oser reprendre
une vie comme si finalement ça y est
c'était terminé et reprendre la vie
qu'ils avaient avant quand on a fait une
erreur pareille qu'on a payé c'est très
bien mais on ne reprend pas la vie qu'on
avait avant quand c'est une vie publique
comme ça je retournais faire de la
musique et donner du bonheur aux gens
alors qu'il a tué une femme et qui les
prix de quelques années de prison pour
moi c'est une honte
donc c'est à lui que je l'appelle c'est
même pas aux fans et tous à lui comme un
petit lui vous remonter sur scène
alors ça me surprend en 200 2018 le père
de marie tron titre trintignant jean
louis était invité sur france 5 dans
l'émission
entrée libre il était bouleversé
affaibli bien sûr confiée à claire
chazal qu'il n'arrivait toujours pas à
faire le deuil quinze ans après le
meurtre de sa fille c'est vrai qu'on
bien sûr garde centre 15 ans au mois
d'août que marie est morte et comment on
se remet au départ je vais dire parce
qu'après au fil des années sans doute ça
se transforme se souvient un peu à quoi
moi depuis 15 ans je suis ça m'a
complètement abattu ouais m'enfin je
suis mariée à 15 ans
lesquels mais on vit quand même
mais jean-michel oui je suis désolé mais
on peut pas séparer l'homme de son
oeuvre et dans quel autre pays dans quel
pays on voit un meurtre y monter sur
scène pour se faire acclamer
est-ce qu'on a d'autres exemples a par
contre est-ce qu'à d'autres gens qui se
font à clamer en étant en meurtrier
n'est ce pas et quel exemple si vous
arrêtez écouter ce disque il avait
laissé une oeuvre la postérité
ça suffit c'est déjà pas mal qu'est ce
qu'un vrai pour toute discrétion ne
répondait à ses caisses que je vais
répondre à ça cédric son oeuvre c'est
certain on peut toujours l'écouté mais
nos quel droit on peut empêcher des gens
qui aiment ce que ce pli fait le
l'empêcher d'aller l'écouter
les gens qui bon
au concert de bertrand cantat qui vont
et qui vont acheter ces allemandes ils
sont quand même atteindre par certaines
émotions
ce n'est pas les bons quand vous allez
au concert vous vous n'avez aucun
respect pour vous y allez aucun vous
êtes vous dormez bien valérie par
exemple le peuplier aller que vous vous
arrivez vous vous dissocier l'artiste de
l'homme en fait c'est ça examinons le
l'artiste associé de longue son oeuvre
et des chaussées d'hollande exemple un
exemple vous connais alors je sais pas
je vais prendre un exemple littéraire le
marquis de sade a passé sa vie en prison
est ce que c'est pour autant il a dit
qu'il a créé des oeuvres ne sont pas
quatre fois contre moi je me suis
replongé dans les coupures de presse de
l'époque s'est passé ce n'est pas
seulement un un accident il a massacré
une femme c'est pas un coup c'est pas
une claque c'est pas deux claques
c'est 3 à 4,5 à laver le visage enfoncé
le crâne enfoncé le nez enfoncé elle a
été massacrée et pour ces raisons là
alors on peut c'est devenu un symbole
des femmes battues il peut pas se
présenter devant un public et se faire
applaudir c'est pas possible
après qu'il ait du talent c'est un autre
débat mais ce qu'est ce qu'a fait ce mec
c'est bien plus qu'un ce crime
passionnel il a massacré à coups de
poing une femme dit lui a tout écrasé ça
c'est pato les relents le 12 mars 2018
france 2 consacré un numéro de son
magazine stupéfiants à la sphère
bertrand cantat et les missions étaient
allés à la rencontre de nadine
trintignant la mère de marie trintignant
à l'aller pousse un gros coup de gueule
contre le retour de bertrand cantat sur
scène elle trouvé ça dégueulasse regard
est ce que vous comprenez nadine
trintignant qui est des gens qui ont
envie d'aller le voir en concert
je me demande ce que les gens qui y vont
pense qu est-ce qui font du sens des
cons des larmes et ne doit pas se
produire en public c'est ça votre
position se faire applaudir après avoir
tué je trouve honteux indécents des de
la ce
voilà c'est vrai que quand on voit ça
s'est dit assez confiant
vous êtes non alors dites nous pourquoi
alors je suis maintenant c'est qu'il ne
fallait pas annuler leur taux de 6 à 9
ans et kelly pourquoi te bats lama moi
je ne fais que répondre à la question
fallait-il annuler retour sur scène de
bertrand cantat je réponde non parce que
je pense que c'est contreproductif mois
contre 1 va vous je déteste et l'homme
et l'oeuvre est encore plus le
maintenant mais en revanche fallait-il
admis non parce que je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus fort si ils chantent de
plus en plus devant des salles vides
qu'on a cassé un bras droit d'assumer ça
tu peux décrocher dès janvier est ce
qu'elles sont belles les salles cédric
alors les salles sont pleines le concert
qui a été qui a été annulé aujourd'hui
ils étaient contre il était complet en
une journée pas comme les autres la
mauvaise amis qui doute mais je pense
que c'est complet vos amis qui doute qui
se voulait le mail au fond ils n'avaient
pas dans cette 500c j'ai des amis qui
doit tueur la vie je vais remettre
vous ne prenez pas en compte salaires
femme de cantat parce que si on va lui
rester n'a pas suffi d il a été
absolument épouse
j'aurais pas question répond avec la loi
juste application de la loi tant qu'il a
payé ça va voir la vidéo dans l'instant
le la mère de marie trintignant avait
également donné son avis sur le fait que
bertrand cantat puisse reprendre son
travail
et après tout ce qui s'est passé ce que
vous disais il ya un instant pour nadine
trintignant
quand on n'a pas le droit de revenir
dans la lumière regarder car qui a été
condamné qu'à purger sa peine
est-ce qu'il a le droit de reprendre son
travail et de revenir dans la lumière
pas dans ce travail là sûrement pas
pourquoi parce qu'il a tué
tout simplement parce qu'il a tué
si elle veut se réaliser en tant
qu'artiste il peut écrire pour des
chanteurs qui eux n'ont pas tué ils sont
plus nombreux que merci alors vous vous
dites mais j'ai pas eu le temps de
changer de côté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurai accès vous êtes tout sur lui et
le pot c'est pas lui qui va lui son truc
quoi bon alors oui je vois puis à deux
écoles qui savent ce que vous avez reçu
des menaces de mort en plus un sur votre
site
des gens qui pendant dix ans j'ai reçu
les grosses discussions
disons que sur le groupe sur la page
facebook
moi qui mets
on a essayé quand même d'avoir des
relations correctes et des naga sera des
débats c'est oui alors vous j'attendais
j'ai même pas vu c'est oui ou alors oui
j'ai vu que donc deux écoles ça m'a
permis de comprendre que deux écoles
s'affrontent est une qui fait place ou
langue de la justice et qui dit il a
déjà payé une autre qui est dit c'est
impardonnable aux éclats pour résumer
les choses qui arrivent
fini faisant sondages les gens savent
raboter merci ce que résume pas bien
c'est pas faire c'est que non c'est faux
on évacue bien on accepte qu'ils
reviennent sur scène mais il faut bien
nous entendre bat et là on doit se
prendre des sceaux de merde sur des
canons je vais vous dire attendre celle
de champion il a fait ce qu'il a fait
est détestable on vomit le mec je pense
qu isabelle est d'accord mais la loi
c'est la loi je veux dire vous pouvez
pas aller tous les débats
c'est que l'émotion pour le tas sur la
loi je suis désolé non je sais bien des
centres et de thézan font réagir les
enfants et moi mais moi qui ai deux
filles mais tu sais quand tu leur dis à
tes filles et moi moi moi il fait sa une
de mes filles moi j'suis pas qu'on peut
atteindre et noir
c'est nous la sculpture en beauté tout
cas perso voilà il fait par la moralité
de 2 dans laquelle l'algérie comme ça
merci risque est choquant qui dit
spectacle dit promotion et moi allons
mois lire à 50 ha à longueur de colonnes
dire qu'il est tourmenté par oui non
mais enfin je m'appelle thomas géraldine
c'est à dire on a tous envie d'être
acclamé et applaudi amis moi je pense
qu'il ya le penalty qui n'a pas droit
d'interdire les concerts mais il ya
aussi la morale est le bon sens alors
enfin ce sur ce plateau on parle d'un
vrai rocker mais malheureusement c'est
pas pour les bonnes raisons
et moi je pense que tout simplement il
faut juste penser à la famille et la
famille c'est primordial et on peut pas
infliger ça les réseaux sociaux ou
instagram twitter ils vont ça va être
relayée partout et ça peut pas être dans
l'intimité parce qu'un concert c'est pas
en intimité à la fin donc c'est pas
possible je discussions alesi cédric
tous ici on vous parlait de promotion de
bertrand cantat savez vous que quel est
le spectacle était en préparation et
qu'est ce qu'il devait faire
non c'est quoi ces cfr et la poésie avec
de la musique pas alors ce n'est pas de
la poésie c'est un roman adapté avec de
la musique il n'ya pas tant de promotion
que ça bertrand cantat ne remonte pas
sur scène pour faire l'exemple serre il
essaie de rester quand même plutôt
discret elle vient pas alors qu'un
peuple a selon lui il ya plein de
personnalités qui ont à 12 ans quand tu
réalises sur la sphère compta depuis des
années des années
premier exemple en septembre 2010 est
sur le plateau de laurent ruquier dans
on n'est pas couché françois cluzet
c'était complètement lâché sur bertrand
cantat regardez c'est court mais on sent
que c'est sincère
janis et john sachets adoré ça c'est un
film de dingue
évidemment c'est le souvenir avec marie
puisque les morte juste après assassiné
par cet [ __ ] de cantat est donc ça a
été un souvenir fantastique pour moi
parce que
je me prenais pour john lennon voilà
alors c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas été
tendre
il ya aussi un autre extrait fort c'est
samuel benchetrit l'ancien époux de
marie trintignant avec qui ils ont un
enfant prénommé jules s'y est exprimé
lui aussi sur bertrand quotas il avait
même traité de lâche en direct c'était
sur lci regarder ses instincts lâche un
faible c'est un type cas pas de couilles
ce type a tué de ses mains la mère de
mon fils il a enlevé une femme libre
extraordinaire à ses parents aux gens
qu'il aimait dont je fais partie qui
chante autant qu'il veut mais c'est sa
façon de réapparaître qui est indigne
dégueulasse voilà ce qui se passe c'est
tout le temps à des sens et on dirait
qu'on parle d'eux
évidemment qu'on parle lui l'a payé sa
dette c'est pas le problème c'est la
façon de réapparaître si on fait de la
peine
une seule personne il faut le faire
autrement merci on va voir le fond d'âge
tout de suite regardé ce qu'on pense les
gens dit oui à 70% non à 34% en tout cas
merci d'avoir des battues avec nous ces
briques